at times it can feel like everyone in
Britain is going on strike but how
significant is this industrial action in
a historical context and should we
really be bracing ourselves for another
winter of discontent let's take a look
at the number of working days lost to
strike action now this is the number of
workers on strike multiplied by the
number of days they've not worked and it
doesn't look that significant in recent
years not like the 2011 public sector
strikes or the 2014 public sector
strikes but it has been climbing during
the pandemic the line is flat because
statisticians stopped collecting the
data this chart it goes up to August
Borough expecting it to climb a lot
higher we know that up to 40 000 Railway
workers and up to 300 000 nurses are
braced to go on strike before Christmas
and these strikes they're going to be
pretty short-lived there's been a shift
towards shorter bursts of action between
one and three days nothing like the
1980s when you could see strike action
last well into a year and which sectors
are driving this increase well you may
have guessed it's the transport and
communication sectors that includes
Railway workers it includes postal
workers and the number of working days
lost to strike action in these sectors
it's at its highest since records began
in 2008. and why a workers going on
strike well quite simply because their
pay is not keeping up with inflation
here you can see the blue bars show real
wages rising and the red bars show real
wages falling that means wages are not
keeping up with inflation and since
November last year wages have been
falling so after a decade of wage
stagnation workers are not prepared to
see their living standards fall even
further but all of this strike action it
does come with a cost to the economy